♪
>> Tucker: OH THAT TIME HAS
COME.
THE TIME FOR FINAL EXAM
WHERE TWO HARD NEWS
PROFESSIONALS COMPETE TO
FIND OUT WHO HAS BEEN PAYING
CLOSER ATTENTION WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE WORLD THIS
PAST WEEK.
OUR DEFENDING CHAMPION THIS
WEEK FOX NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
GOING FOR HIS SECOND WIN IN
HIS CHALLENGER FOR THE VERY
FIRST EDITION OF THIS
SEGMENT IS FOX NEWS
ELIZABETH PRANN.
THEY BOTH JOIN US ON SET.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH.
I KNOW YOU KNOW THE RULES.
>> I DO KNOW THE RULES.
THE FUTURE CHAMPION KNOWS
THE RULES.
>> Tucker: FOR THE SAKE OF
OUR VIEWERS TUNING IN I WILL
REPEAT THEM.
FIRST ONE BUZZING IN GETS TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH ASKING
IT BEFORE YOU ANSWER IT EACH
CORRECT ANSWER ONE POINT.
EACH INCORRECT GETS A POINT
SUBTRACTED FROM YOUR TOTAL.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I'M SO READY.
ARE YOU READY.
>> I HAVE BEEN PRACTICING.
>> I'M ROOTING FOR ME AS
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
TELL.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE NOT ON
YOUR OWN SIDE WHO WILL BE.
WHICH DEMOCRATIC SENATOR
CHASTISED HILLARY CLINTON
THIS WEEK SAYING VOTERS FROM
HER STATE ARE LOOKING
BACKWARD?
PETER DOOCY?
>> I THINK THAT THAT IS
HEIDI HEITCAMP.
>> Tucker: YOU PREFACED THAT
BY SAYING I THINK.
>> I THOUGHT ENOUGH TO RING
THE ALARM.
>> Tucker: RING THE ALARM.
ALSO KNOWN AS THE BUZZER.
WAS IT HEIDI HEITKAMP.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> MISSOURI SENATOR CLAIRE
MCCASKILL SLAMMING HILLARY
CLINTON ON WHY SHE LOST THE
2016 ELECTION.
IT FELT LIKE SHE WAS
CRITICIZING MISSOURI VOTERS
AND I WOULD DRAW -- TALKING
ABOUT DRAWING A LINE, I
WOULD DRAW A LINE THERE I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
MISSOURI VOTERS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
SOME OF WHICH I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND.
[BUZZER]
>> Tucker: MISSOURI SENATOR
HAS COMPLETE RESPECT FOR
MISSOURI VOTERS BUT NOT FOR
NORTH DAKOTA VOTERS THOUGH.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
>> I WAS GOING TO COME OUT I
DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: I DIDN'T EITHER
ACTUALLY.
>> I KNOW THIS ONE FOR SURE.
>> Tucker: ROSEANNE BAR NOT
A SENATOR SAYS LIBERALS
BECAME TOO EXTREME DURING
THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE OTHER NIGHT SHE CON
FRONTED A LIGHT NIGHT SHOW
HOST FOR GOING TOO FAR TO
THE LEFT.
WHO DID SHE CONFRONT?
ELIZABETH PRANN.
>> STEPHEN COLBERT.
>> Tucker: DID SHE CONFRONT
STEPHEN COLBERT?
>> I'M SHOCKED BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU WERE VERY LIBERAL,
SOCIALLY LIBERAL PERSON IN
GENERAL.
>> I'M STILL THE SAME.
Y'ALL MOVED.
>> WE DID?
>> Y'ALL WENT SO [BLEEP] FAR
OUT, YOU LOST EVERYONE.
>> I DIDN'T SAY STEPHEN
COLBERT I SAID JIMMY KIMMEL.
IT SOUNDED LIKE THE S AND
THE J.
>> Tucker: BOTH ARE KIND OF
FRENCH NAMES.
SO FORTH FARES TIME IN THE
HISTORY OF THE SHOW WE HAVE
NEGATIVE 1 TO NEGATIVE 1.
THREE MORE.
SOMEONE CAN GET TO ZERO IF
WE TRY HARD.
QUESTION THREE, OCTOBER IN
SPACE RIGHT NOW THE SIZE OF
A SCHOOL BUS AND FALLING TO
EARTH AS WE SPEAK THERE IS A
SLIGHT CHANCE IT COULD HIT
THE UNITED STATES.
ELIZABETH PRANN?
>> CHINESE SPACE STATION.
>> Tucker: CHINESE SPACE
STATION.
IS IT A CHINESE SPACE
>> CHINESE SPACE STATION
LOSING COMMUNICATIONS WITH
AN 18,000-POUND.
>> COME DOWN SOMEWHERE.
>> MOST OF IT WILL BURN UP
10 TO 40% OF IT WILL REACH
THE EARTH.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU GO.
>> ONLY ONE I WILL GET
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: TAKING THE LEAD
AT ZERO.
>> ARE WE DONE?
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT.
WE HAVE TWO MORE.
YOU CAN GET IN POSITIVE
TERRITORY.